[Musique]
trouver sa tenue de réveillon pour les
hommes c'est assez simple le
traditionnel smoking mais pour les
femmes c'est souvent le cas ce texte
la télévision l'a bien compris et
conseils téléspectatrices sur le choix
de leurs tenues dans les années 50
époque où les femmes sont
majoritairement au foyer les émissions
féminine leur propose des modèles à
faire soi même
vous avez certainement l'intention
d'être très élégante pour les fêtes de
fin d'année cette robe de ger et
noisettes la meilleure exécuté avec 2 m
62 jersey en 140 bien nous l'espérons à
point pour combler vos désirs
dans les années 60 la société change les
femmes abandonnent leur machine à coudre
classe à la variété de vêtements et de
matières la petite lucarne se transforme
en vitrine scintillante fourreau brodé
robe de satin ou robes en strass la
télévision vend du rêve aux femmes
aimées les grands couturiers à l'honneur
des robes fabuleuse pour la nuit de la
saint sylvestre où les femmes sont les
plus belles
dans les années 70 l'arrivée de la
minijupe révolutionne les réveillons
alors robes courtes ou longues pour le
la télé ne tranche pas et bien pour le
très grand soir les robes très longues
oui mais sans cela les robes courtes
sont très belles et les femmes ont envie
de montrer
art jambes enfin 70 le disque au
chamboule les lucs la télé s'adapte et
c'est en boîte de nuit qu'elle prodigue
ses traditionnels conseils
vestimentaires les paillettes toujours
au rendez vous mais le mauvais goût
aussi comme cette idée de ferro un
diadème de boules de plastique épinglé
sur un ruban le matériel coûte 30 francs
mais pour la robe
il vaudrait mieux avoir un élevage
d'autruches dans les années 80 les
paillettes ont de la concurrence pour
les téléspectatrices les habits de fête
se décline désormais autour du jean et
une nouvelle fois la collection louis
féraud fait mouche différents conseils
le lamellé plumes avec le denim le plus
c'est dans les années 90 le
prêt-à-porter remplacent les grands
couturiers à la télévision plus de robes
de rêve mais une tenue simple et
réutilisables et on remet ça rend beau
ou sa jupe ou son pantalon pour aller
travailler avec un grand voile à de
nouvelles pratiques apparaissent dans
les années 2000 la tenue de fêtes de
grands couturiers ont la loue alors
20.31 une très jolie petite robe gucci
voilà toute simple en jersey de soie
avec un dos bénitier c'est juste une
merveille une manière économique de
retrouver le chic des réveillons d'antan
[Musique]